the jurogan experience
you're just used to things that are less
comfortable than most
cozy in your perspective you know but i
get it yeah
yeah but this uh ice hotel my friend who
stayed i can't remember who told me they
stayed in it
they did it one night just to say they
did it they were at their kids too
uh it sounds like david blaine i think
you're right you're right i think you
know david
yeah he's great yeah dude yeah he he for
him a ice hotel is like a normal thing
he's like he probably just lay there on
the ice the whole time just to
just see if he's good he's just yeah
he's a strange person right
strange and powerful at the same time
like a very unusual human being
dude i uh i met with him years ago now
because he was did you see his like real
or magic documentary no
it's really good i would totally
encourage you to watch it but basically
it's all these like sort of magic tricks
except they aren't actually tricks
they're just like
i'm allowed to curse right yeah yeah so
like these [ __ ] up things that he does
that people assume must be magic but
aren't like he puts an ice pick through
his hand
i put an ice pick through his arm oh
whether yeah that's like the same kind
of made me
yeah exactly i'm like come on man what
are we doing here exactly
though exactly and you're like you're
like you hope it's a trick
dude exactly dude he bought me an iphone
right randomly yeah it was one of those
classic things
he uh i forget he yeah so i met him in
new york for this thing for real magic
because
uh he was talking about maybe doing a
climbing thing
and i was totally into teaching him how
to climb the outside of a building
basically because it's one of those
things that
people would assume there's a trick to
it but in some ways it's actually easier
just to learn how to do it well enough
that you can just do it rather than do a
trick
you know what i mean like because that's
kind of the whole thing with the ice
pick because people assume there must be
a trick to it
but you actually just do this crazy
thing you just learn how to do it right
right and so so i went climb with him a
few times and he like
you know gave me two around town and we
chat and stuff i don't know i was
totally into
his whole scene i was like such mind
over matter you know i was like wow he
he has got a strong mind for just like
making himself do things that other
people would think
are impossible slash yeah it's just
mostly his mind
mostly the ability to deal with
uncomfortable feelings yeah
like the ice picked through the arm like
we had to stop because i hit a nerve and
then we did it again
so it hit a nerve and then there was one
point in time where
after we did it he was concerned that
maybe
blood was pooling up in a weird way so
he had our medic
look at it so he stu we stopped twice
right we stopped
once and i put it back in again and then
we go all the way
through and then after it came out we
had to stop again
and then one of our guys had to look at
it because it was
it's just bleeding in a weird way he was
worried that was creating a hematoma
it could be like come on yeah if you
ever watch
the the show you know real or magic
whatever it's it's really good but in
one of them
like he puts the ice pick through his
hand and and then
he pulls it out and he's like look see
it's fine and it's like and it looks
totally fine like it's not bleeding you
know it's because your hand is so
elastic or whatever
but i asked him about it you know i was
like oh what's the deal with that
because you pull out you know it's like
is it a trick
and he's like no you pull it out and as
long as you're holding your hand above
your heart it doesn't bleed for a little
bit
he's like then when you put your hand
down obviously it bleeds because you
have [ __ ] hold through your hand i
was like oh jesus
this is like oh like that's not much of
a trick that's that's messed up but one
of the things that he showed us
was there was a guy that was famous back
in the day for
putting swords through his body because
the guy would run right in the hallway
mm-hmm
the whole way was oregon really yeah a
small but they got
progressively larger as you got more
basically better
is that how he died do you remember
jamie i i
feel like that's how it ended up going
he got cocky yes he got caught
or he sneezed halfway through and just
like lacerated eventually made his way
to like a broadsword size
it was really weird to see though
because there's video of this guy
and there's photos video is there video
i got video over here
yeah this guy slid like right through
his organs
oh geez yeah so look at this oh geez
i mean they just puncture his
lung with a [ __ ] sword
i mean this is not a trick this is when
you watch action movies and people get
shot or stabbed a bunch of times and
you're like that's so unrealistic
like when you watch john wick you know
and he gets shot like 27 times
like apparently people can actually uh
take quite a beating and just keep going
or they can get one small look at
they're going right through this
right through his [ __ ] dude oh my
gosh right to this organization
and look how he just sat sits there and
i guess
who's this doctor who's like good enough
to poke a sword straight
he's not really a doctor well but he
must be a like he'd be an incredible uh
maybe he works in a deli
you know like a really really good i
mean did you say what year this is
what are the things on his forearms by
the way oh so now he's going into an
x-ray machine to make sure that
so this guy had scars all over his body
from the times that he did this
dude yeah yikes that's a [ __ ]
fairly thick blade like definitely
bigger than a pencil that the doctors
examined in it
looks good and now he's going to eat
except it's all going to fall out the
hole yeah it's going to score it out
that's a hard looking man imagine having
a conversation with that dude
i bet he has a very weird way of looking
at things dude
he died at 36. that guy oh well there
you go he looked like he was 50 already
let's fill the holes i wonder how
painful that is i mean it's got to be
as [ __ ] yeah how could it not be yeah
you know
[ __ ] piercing your ear is painful
i've never preached my ear
too afraid that's hilarious you're too
afraid about
you're here well no i just don't want to
hole in my ear so did he die
from that jamie i'm double checking on
how he died
yeah you need like a team of researchers
and you're just like pulling up uh
like yeah checking fast i know it's all
jamie one-handed googling
like a wizard he moved to switzerland
and was granted a license to perform
without the ability to speak to the
public i don't know that sounds strange
a license to perform without the ability
to
oh maybe like if you performed you had
to talk to people
like they had mimes back then though no
maybe you had a break character i don't
know they get mad at you but that seems
like so maybe he couldn't stay he got he
was like ow it hurts and they're like
i don't know like this is so silly
to be fair the the act is less inspiring
if the guy screams in pain the whole
time because then nobody wants to watch
right yeah i mean the same guy doing the
same thing
screaming like like he's being tortured
that would be scary and it'd be the same
for david blaine like when you watch the
david stuff it's like if you were
putting an ice pick through his arm and
he was just great like if he was just
sobbing the whole time he'd be like i
don't want to watch this i wouldn't do
it
it's like uh it says in 1948 he was
alleged he was instructed by voices to
eat a steel
needle and two days later it was
surgically removed
i don't know i think he got cocky it's
fair to say that he might have some
weird things
going on yeah he's probably trying to
kill himself and couldn't believe he
kept surviving yeah he was laying on a
bed they didn't
i guess they didn't know he was dead and
then they finally got a doctor to check
him
turns out he'd already been dead for a
day
yeah it sounds a little jesus christ we
need we need like three more uh research
interns like googling his whole scene as
fast again because they're like wait
none of that makes any sense and this
was
because of swallowing a needle mm-hmm
he said he had he thought he had
guardian angels he said he was
telepathic he could heal people
yeah yeah no he didn't heal himself very
well
or maybe he did that's how he survived
somebody's you know being impaled so
many times
i guess you can just do it though it can
be done you know because
they're fairly small holes although they
do go through the length of your entire
body
it's i mean you just think you'd get
infected with i think that's part of
part of what that video was was
improving the doctors that it wasn't all
fake
and that's because that's what it says
he proved to zurich doctors that it
wasn't
his act wasn't based on fakery why do i
get so uncomfortable
just talking about this i'm so i'm
breathing heavy i'm like
maybe you need to practice a little bit
you have somebody start putting needles
through like little parts of your arm
you know like just there's just
something weird about people that are
willingly hurting themselves and causing
themselves pain
no i i kind of agree with that i do i do
find it slightly
but david very well adjusted man it
seems very well just very friendly you
know
super fast guy and his card tricks are
legitimately mind-blowing
dude so fun fact about his cartrix i
don't know if he'd be so
he uh he took me to lunch once and like
did a whole thing in card tricks and i
was totally i love magic and i think
it's cool and
you know i like obviously they're all
tricks but i was like this is incredible
the execution is incredible i was
totally into it i was super impressed
and then uh at the time i was i was
dating this girl in new york really
briefly and um
and a couple days later we all went to
the climbing gym together because
like i said i was kind of encouraging
him to like do some some climbing thing
and he then went to lunch again and he
basically did the same set of card
tricks for this girl that i was dating
but having already climbed for like an
hour or two and it was funny because his
execution on the card tricks was
noticeably worse for me like you know i
could tell that he was like
doing all his tricks worse once his arms
were like totally wrecked from climbing
for two hours like basically his fingers
and his forearms are totally wrecked
and that actually made me appreciate how
difficult the tricks are even more
because i was like oh wow like if your
fingertips hurt and your muscles erect
and it's hard for you to hold your arms
steady
then it's like very hard to fan the deck
you know evenly and to like
pick cards properly and it made me
appreciate just how much skill is
involved and what he was doing
i was like oh dude it's pretty cool you
know basically to see somebody do
something at their peak and then when
they're also totally wrecked and then to
see kind of the overlap you're like oh
this is actually quite hard like what
he's doing is
is is a challenge you know you know what
it's like he's like
he's got the fine motor skills that we
have for tying our own shoes
totally but for a deck of cards yeah
yeah when he can just cut to the 27th
card or whatever
you know and he's like let me just cut
this deck and he's like oh there's card
number 24. and you're like really
can do that yeah we've done it so many
times
that he has that you know that because
there is that feeling that you have when
you tie your shoe
where your hands just communicate so
fluidly
you know like that's like what people
strive for in jiu jitsu
jiu jitsu you strive like that's
actually what my uh
my coach eddie bravo he uses that as as
an example
that when you tie your shoe you don't
think about tying your shirt you just
tie your shoe
and in a certain situation you'll flow
into a technique like a technique will
happen and it'll it'll happen
and because you your repetitions you've
hit so many times it'll just be
so fluid and so for david it's got to be
like that but with like the
very tips of his fingers i know for
somebody like me
with you know very callous i can't even
imagine feeling anything though
like honestly decks of cards i just like
crumple them all together i'm just
shoving them
like is it shuffled you know like i
can't even manipulate them that well
yeah i would imagine right like your
hands have to be like super rough right
yeah normally pretty rough and then also
just really callous on the tip so i mean
often you know i can pick up like hot
things and like not really notice it
quite the same way or you know of course
i mean if you're grabbing like
grabbing a very coarse rock all the time
you have to wind up with really callous
fingertips of course
yeah but so then something like
manipulating the edge of a card it's
like i can't even imagine feeling it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience